donc selon vous il faudrait abolir le
vieux chastet moi je pense que ça fait
longtemps c'est pas nouveau qu'on le dit
mais
l'obligation à la chasteté qui concerne
les pasteurs je ne parle pas des moines
qui eux choisissent une voie très
minoritaire très difficile et qui s'y
engage il y a des moines chrétiens il y
a des moines bouddhistes le monachisme
est un phénomène assez universel mais
ici ce dont il est question c'est les
gens qui ont une responsabilité de
s'occuper des autres chrétiens
transmettent la parole de les aider à
tous égards ces gens-là depuis le 5ème
siècle ont graduellement on a cherché à
dire il faut qu'il soit aussi parfait
que les moines ils sont des gens
distingués des autres ils sont sacrés
ceci c'est des facto terminé dans
l'opinion on ne pense plus ça pourquoi
l'Église continue-t-elle à faire comme
si c'était possible et donc est obligé
souvent de cacher les choses parce
découvrons que des actes mauvais sont
compris